Even though it’s 4,500 years old, the Great
Pyramid of Giza still has some secrets.
Recently we discovered a new one, and we did
it using subatomic particles from space.
The particles in question are called Muons,
and they’re like relatives of electrons
if electrons really let themselves go; a muon
has about 200 times more mass than an electron.
They’re generated when cosmic rays --usually
protons from stars-- collide with particles
in our upper atmosphere.
The newly formed muons rain down and about
10,000 hit every square meter of the earth’s
surface every minute.
You may have noticed, or not noticed rather,
that you’re not getting pummeled to death
by a particle shower all the time.
That’s because muons pass right through
stuff with ease.
It’s what tipped off 1930s quantum physicists
that what they were looking at wasn’t some
type of electron, but it’s own distinct
elementary particle.
Even though they can travel through the densest
materials, that doesn’t mean they’re unaffected
by them.
Muons have a negative charge, meaning when
they come near electrons, their like charge
repels the muon, deflecting it and slowing
it down.
Since muons decay into electrons and neutrinos
after just 2 millionths of a second, really
dense materials can slow some muons down enough
to stop them, but many will still make it
through.
Scientists can use these properties to give
them x-ray vision.
Actually it’s better than x-ray vision,
because x-rays can be blocked by dense materials
while muons can come clean out the other side.
Really Superman should have had muon vision,
instead of dumb old x-ray vision.
That’s right, I’m suggesting they nerfed
Superman.
Anyway, scientists can use muons to see through
buildings using a technique called Muon Tomography.
Muons travel more slowly through materials
with higher atomic numbers, so by measuring
how muons from cosmic rays are deflected when
they pass though a big stone building, scientists
can map out what they must have passed through.
And there’s no bigger or stonier building
than the Great Pyramid of Giza.
Well technically there is, but you get the
idea.
Plus since the pyramid is so dang old, it’d
be best to explore it in a way that doesn’t
harm it.
For that muon tomography is a perfect fit.
In December of 2015 researchers put a muon
detector inside the pyramid in what’s known
as the “Queen’s Chamber.”
Sure enough their results showed a heretofore
undiscovered void, and two separate teams
using different kinds of muon detectors in
different locations inside and outside the
pyramid confirmed the findings.
The void is the first new discovery of a major
space inside the pyramid since the 19th century,
although scientists did try and use muon detectors
inside it back in the 1960s but the technology
was not as sensitive then as it is now.
Muon detectors have come a long way, especially
since September 11th, 2001, when fears of
a terrorist attack spurred research into technology
that could detect hidden nuclear weapons.
Today muon detectors can scan a 40 foot shipping
container in 45 seconds, revealing any nuclear
materials inside.
And there’s no use trying to hide a bomb
by shielding it with lead, because the muons
can go right through that too and the scanners
will just show that there’s a bomb AND some
lead.
As much as I’m glad that muon detectors
are helping to keep us safe, I just love that
some mad genius thought to use them in the
pyramids.
Where else are you going to find such an awesome
convergence of astronomy, particle physics,
and egyptology?
Besides Stargate, obviously.
Want more Seeker?
You can find us on TV under the name SEEKER
NOW!
Watch SEEKER NOW on TBD Wednesdays 9pm/8c!
To find TBD in your area and stream it anywhere,
download the TBD What’s Next app or visit
TBD.COM, Thanks for watching Seeker! We're always making new videos so you should go ahead and subscribe for more.
Muon detectors have also been used at Fukushima
to map out where nuclear materials inside
the damaged reactors are.
That disaster is still ongoing, and we’ve
just found a new source of radiation.
Trace has more on that here.
That’s all for now, thanks for watching
Seeker!